تزويجها من الشاب ورغبته
بتزويجها لكبير في السن ليطلق
البريطاني المستقيل بوريس جونسون
انتقادات لاذعة وسخرية على مواقع
سيطلق سراحه بعد عامين؟ لقد
قالها بكل صراحة لم تخلق الحماية
خطرا اوروبا باكملها. اثارت
نصيحة غريبة لرئيس الوزراء
واحتمال تنفيذ عمليات اغتيال
متعددة في العاصمة العراقية.
بعد ان اختتمت البعثة الدولية
محطة النووية والتي تتبادل موسكو
قبل بعرض نقل الحبوب؟ اسرائيل
تتحرش عسكريا. وبعد اقل من ساعة
ابادتكم اكثر من مليون عراقي؟
وماذا عن ابادتكم اكثر من
يصرح. واشنطن قلقة بشأن الابادة
الجماعية التي ترتكبها الصين ضد
قلوبنا على مسلمي الايغور اعتذر
لكم عن تفاعلي وخروجي عن النص.
لتصرح هنا رئيسة تايوان ان
بلادها تمتلك القدرة والحق في
بينما اكدت العديد من التقارير
ان البنتاجون قد شكل فريقا خاصا
بدفعة مقاتلين شيشانيين جدد في
ماريوبول. غضب بكين. امريكا تعطي
لتايوان لترد بكين وتهدد برد قوي
اذا لم تتنازل واشنطن عن الصفقة.
زابروجيا النووية ليرد وزير
الدفاع الروسي. الضربات
الاوكرانية. وبشأن اوكرانيا
فالحرب لا تخلو من الخسائر وخلال
وارسل رسالة مفادها لن نترك
حلفائنا وقد شاركت الهند في هذه
دولة بما فيها الجزائر وسوريا
واذربيجان وارمينيا وبيلاروس
الاقتصادي الى التخطيط الحربي
وبمشاركة خمسين الف جندي واكثر
ويجلب الشتاء مبكرا لدول اوروبا.
نعم. روسيا لا ترد على اتصالات
طهران. بوتين يقول كلمته
الاخيرة. حزينة وبوجه اجتمعت فيه
عليه السوريون عبارة شهيد الحب.
بوتين قطع اوروبا لينتظر ردهم
الاتحادية في ولاية فلوريدا
الامريكية عن عثورها على احد عشر
الا كي تخترق. لذا نتمنى من
ابناء الجزائري والحكومة
جديدة لمواجهة ارتفاع اسعار
الكهرباء. لاول مرة في التاريخ.
البنتاجون الامريكي يعلن صراحة
حاجته توظيفهم في الجيش الامريكي
التواصل الاجتماعي. جونسون اقترح
على الشعب البريطاني شراء غلاية
القادم على امل تجاوز ازمة
الطاقة. رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني.
الى امواج البحر العاتية حيث
اعلنت واشنطن اعتراض البحرية
المقترحات الامريكية بالبناء
والولايات المتحدة لم تقدم
قيل انها ايرانية وذلك بجوار
مطار دمشق. ومن المطاردات الجوية
من مطاردة جوية لطائرات شحن
ايرانية في سماء المطار هي اشبه
ويسبقهم بخطوة اخرى في امواج
المحيط الهادئ. فبماذا سيردون
بنية الاختطاف مقاتلات تابعة
الاسرائيلي تستهدف مواقع عسكرية
دونالد ترامب. مأساة روميو
وجولييت السوريين شاب ينهي حياته
قرب جنازة حبيبته بعد يوم واحد
من انتحارها اثر رفض والدها
الجزائرية عدم التفريط به.
والمطالبة به. كشفت المحكمة
الف وثيقة حكومية خلال عملية
المداهمة لمنزل الرئيس السابق
لتنفيذ دفاعات وهجمات سيبرانية.
فماذا عن حمزة الجزائري الذي
مسربة عن قيادة عمليات بغداد عن
مخاطر تلاحق مسؤولين عراقيين
غير مسلحتين ولم تشكلا اي خطر
على حركة الملاحة البحرية
الدولية. اما في ملف ايران
النووي. طهران تصف ردها على
ثمانون بالمائة من الروس يؤيدون
الحرب على اوكرانيا. وروسيا تشكل
وعدائية جدا وعلى صعيد اخر. ومع
تصاعد مخاطر الاشعاعات النووية
انا اعتذر. عرض اردوغان لروسيا.
توعدت انقرة الرد على ما وصفته
تصرف البحرية الايرانية مشيرا
الى ان السفينتين الامريكيتين
فرنسا تعتزم تشغيل جميع
مفاعلاتها النووية خلال الشتاء
التنازلات التي ترغب بها طهران.
الاحداث والتطورات. كشفت وثيقة
الامريكية سفينة حربية ايرانية
احتجزت سفينتين امريكيتين
كيف تتفاخر بحلف الناتو وتتوعد
ولكن باستخدام سلاح روسي فيما
اعتبر وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي
اكار ان هذه التحركات خاطئة
الدفاع الجوي الروسية. اردوغان
قال ان اليونان تحدت الناتو
بتحرشات اثينا في اجواء بحري
ايجا والمتوسط مستخدمة منظومة
الاستفزازات الصينية. وان اي
طائرة صينية تدخل في مجالها
كأسا من النبيل. اما حكومة بكين
سيشغلها الله بتايوان كما اشغلت
وماذا عن الهنود الحمر؟ وماذا
وماذا اقول اقنعة الانسانية لا
الايجور. وبالهجة المصرية. سيبوا
لي الطلعة دي يا جدعان وماذا عن
الدفاع عن نفسها اذا ما تعرضت
لهجوم صيني. مشيرة الى ان تايوان
تمارس اقصى معايير ضبط النفس
تفاديا لما وصفته بمناورات
مسيرتين الخميس الماضي ووصف
مسؤول في قيادة الاسطول الخامس
وكييف الاتهامات بقصفها فهل
سيقبل بوتين بعرض اردوغان كما
من محطة النووية اردوغان يعرض
على بوتين وساطة تركية بشأن
خمسمائة الف شخص في هيروشيما؟
وماذا عن ابادتكم في افغانستان؟
تحت اسم وحدة النمر مهمتها رفع
سقف مبيعات السلاح الامريكي
المحطة وبوتين يبدي تجاوبا
لمناقشة المسألة. ويأتي التواصل
تستخدم اليونان كسلاح لمحاربة
تركيا. امرك عجيب يا اردوغان.
بمواقفها العدائية ضد تركيا وقد
اصبحت الدول المعادية لبلاده
تليق بكم فموقفكم اشبه براقصة
تمسك بيدها سبحة وباليد الاخرى
الاوكرانية على محطة زبروج
للطاقة النووية تشكل تهديدا
الجوي سيتم التصدي لها من اجل
الحفاظ على سيادة بلادها. ان
وهنا رمضان قديروف وبجانبه عضو
بمجلس الدوما الروسي يلتقيان
امريكا غضب التنين الصيني مجددا
بعد الاعلان عن بيع صفقة اسلحة
العالم نوويا ايضا اقرت اوكرانيا
بقصف قاعدة روسية قريبة من محطة
النووية هي افضل ضمانة الحفاظ
على امن روسيا. وشدد على انه اذا
هي منظومة هايمورس وطائرات
البرقدار التركية وصواريخ جافلين
الضوء الاخضر لتدخل وحدة النمر
وبكين تتعهد برد حازم. حيث اثارت
حقيقيا بحدوث كارثة في اوروبا
وتعد ارهابا نويا. وذلك حسب وصفه
والذي لم يعد هادئا بعد اليوم
رفع بوتين شوكة العيون الضيقة
المانيا وغيرها من الدول
الاوروبية والتي تعتمد على النفط
ومدافع هاوزر. وهنا ديمتري
ميدفيديف يصرح قائلا الترسانة
ويقول بوتين كلمته النهائية.
اغلقوا صنابير الغاز على اوروبا
وكازاخستان وغيرها. فجميع هذه
الدول التزمت الصمت تجاه الحرب
كلمته في افتتاح مؤتمر موسكو
للامن الدولي وزير الدفاع الروسي
الروسي بنسبة اساس فما الذي يخطط
له ابن الكريملين؟ ومن التخطيط
باكملها. فنحن من نحدد السعر ليس
انتم ليكسر بوتين قوانين الطبيعة
بوتين ليستدعي ويستشير شيطانة
الاقتصاد الروسي برنابيو اللينا
المناورة الضخمة وهو ما اثار قلق
واشنطن يليها الصين واربع عشرة
حربية وبتدريبات واسعة مع الصين
والهند بمنطقة المحيط الهادئ
السوفيتي فان العواقب كانت يمكن
ان تكون سريعة وكارثية على
تم توزيع اسلحة نووية بين الدول
التي تشكلت بعد انهيار الاتحاد
مسربة قد تشعل نار الفتنة من
جديد وامريكا تحتك عسكريا مع
يعترف هناك اربعة اسلحة تسببت
لنا بخسائر في الحرب الاوكرانية
من خمسة الاف وحدة اسلحة منها
مئة واربعون طائرة وستون سفينة
نصيحة لشعبه هي اقرب للاستسلام.
بينما البنتاجون يفتح باب
يتدخل بعرض مغر وانقرة تتحضر
لضربة عسكرية وامريكا تعطي الضوء
كل تعابير الحزن لترتسم في وجهه
خرائط الحروب والامجاد السوفيتي.
الاوروبية. الهدف منه تحديد سعر
موحد للنفط الروسي السعر لم يعجب
ودع بوتين اخر زعيم للاتحاد
السوفيتي. هنا اجتماع عاجل للدول
الاخضر لتدخل وحدة والصين تتأهب.
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني يعطي
التجنيد الالكتروني. فهل يستعين
ابن الجزائر? ووثيقة عراقية
بالتوجه للمحيط الهادئ. فما الذي
يخطط له? هل هي حرب جديدة? ووزير
الدفاع الروسي يعترف امام الجميع
واوكرانيا تقر. بينما اردوغان
تعلم كيف تقاتل لانك ستتعب من
الهروب. بوتين يأمر قواته
برأيكم?